une forte majorité de Canadiens jugent
que les appareils électroniques les
électroménagers sont de plus en plus
difficiles à réparer le résultat c'est
qu'il y a moins de 20% de tous les
téléphones intelligents les bouilloire
les cuisinières qui sont brisés qui sont
remis en état au lieu d'être jeté c'est
le résultat d'une enquête menée par
equitter on va en discuter avec Amélie
côté il est auteurs du rapport analysent
en réduction à la source les critères
bonsoir madame côté merci d'être là
pourquoi vous êtes intéressés à ça à la
réparabilité des objets du quotidien ça
touche beaucoup de monde effectivement
mais en fait en 2018 équitaire a mené
une étude en canadienne sur
l'obsolescence des appareils
électroniques électroménagers et ce
qu'on a constaté c'était que la
réparation ce serait une solution hyper
concrète pour agir par rapport à
l'obsolescence mais en amont donc pour
l'obsolescence il faut démontrer qu'il y
a un stratagème délibéré de l'entreprise
de réduire la durée de vie d'un objet et
quand on parle de la du droit à la
réparation on met en place des
conditions qui incitent ou qui forcent
les fabricants à mettre en marché des
objets qui sont plus durables qui sont
plus comparable donc ça nous semblait
plus porteur de solutions concrètes pour
changer pour inverser la tendance là vos
constats bon sont assez clairs vous
laissez entendre que il y a à peu près
les deux tiers des appareils qui peuvent
briser dans un délai très court là c'est
deux trois ans tout simplement peu de
gens qui réparent leurs appareils c'est
quoi les frais là pour les Canadiens qui
souhaitent faire réparer leurs appareils
qui brillent mais on a posé la question
à la population canadienne puis
également à des personnes qui font de la
réparation leur métier et le premier
frein qui est ressorti c'est la
conception des appareils donc les
appareils ont beaucoup évolué au fil des
années si on pense aux électroménagers
par exemple ils ont de plus en plus de
composantes électroniques donc ça c'est
complexifié remplissent plus de
fonctions aussi et ça ça vient avec une
complexité qui rend la tâche plus
difficile au niveau de la réparation et
il y a la question aussi de l'accès aux
pièces aux outils à l'information pour
être en mesure de réparer et toute cette
diversité d'appareil là mais ça rend
vraiment la tâche difficile même on
parle de certains outils qui sont très
spécifiques pour réparer un objet en
particulier donc imaginez le casse-tête
des personnes qui font de la réparation
pour avoir accès à tout ça et le
deuxième frein le plus important c'est
la question du coût de la réparation
donc on estime que si ça coûte de 30 à
50 % du prix d'un appareil neuf la
tendance va être d'aller vers un objet
neuf mais clairement en fait même des
fois on essaie de faire réparer un
appareil on se fait dire bah ça va
prendre plusieurs heures de travail ça
va finir par coûter cher le réparer
aller donc en acheter un œuf mais le
consommateur est perdant lui aussi
puisqu'il doit débourser de nouveau tout
le monde n'est perdant quel est le rôle
du fabricant entre autres dans ce
problème là madame côté vous disiez
c'est plus compliqué la façon dont c'est
conceptualiser les outils sont
technologiques c'est quoi leur rôle
qu'est-ce qu'ils doivent faire mais en
fait les appareils doivent être un peu
plus standardisés dans la conception et
on doit favoriser la possibilité de les
ouvrir de les réparer mais également
qu'il soit plus du donc c'est quand même
absurde de penser qu'en ce moment on a
tous en tête un frigo ou un
électroménager qui appartenait à nos
grands-parents qui a duré plusieurs
décennies et maintenant on est chanceuse
si notre notre appareil dur une dizaine
d'années donc pour inverser cette
tendance là malheureusement
l'auto-régulation de l'industrie on
constate ça ne fonctionne ça n'a pas
fonctionné du tout alors ça prend plus
de mordant ça prend des lois oui ça
prend il faut encadrer le droit à la
réparation on le voit ça a commencé en
Europe il y a quelques années et ça
fonctionne on sent déjà des changements
du côté des fabricants donc en janvier
2021 la France a instauré un indice de
réparabilité qui est une note sur 10 qui
nous permet d'avoir l'information sur à
quel point un appareil électronique
électroménager est réparable en fonction
de plusieurs critères notamment l'accès
aux pièces aux outils au manuels à
l'information et tout ceci aussi à un
prix raisonnable parce que la question
du prix elle est primordiale et le délai
de la réparation également et il faut
également penser aux composantes
entourant le coût donc en réduisant la
facture de la réparation c'est aussi
c'est un levier qui est intéressant et
la France est en train de mettre sur
pied cet automne un fond de réparation
qui permet d'appliquer un rabais
directement au moment de l'acte de
réparation et après le réparateur va
obtenir un remboursement de la part de
l'organisme qui gère le système de
responsabilité élargie des produits ben
ça c'est des solutions très concrètes
desquelles on pourrait s'inspirer
clairement mais une question qui nous
vient à l'esprit entre autres à la
lecture de votre rapport vous laissez
entendre que les deux tiers ou presque
des Canadiens qui ont eu un appareil qui
a brisé non même pas pensé à le faire
réparer il y a donc un travail à faire
pour les consommateurs aussi ça fait ben
en fait on a perdu le réflexe de la
réparation ce réflexe là il est perdu
notamment parce qu'on perçoit que les
appareils sont irréparables dans
certains cas ils peuvent l'être mais
après évidemment la question du coût va
ressortir mais on entretenant davantage
nos objets mais on peut aussi s'assurer
de prolonger leur durée de vie parce que
plusieurs des brises aussi à cause
d'entretien qui sont défaillants selon
les réparateurs et réparatrices qu'on a
sondés et vraiment le fait de s'informer
avant d'acheter pour trouver un bien qui
a déjà une réputation d'être réparable
lors de l'information existe en ligne je
pense à par exemple à effectx qui est un
site qui fait un palmarès des appareils
électroniques selon leur réparabilité il
contient qui contient aussi une foule de
tutoriels pour être en mesure de réparer
donc toutes ces informations là peuvent
nous permettre de nous assurer que les
objets qu'on achète sont davantage
durables ce que j'aime madame côté c'est
que vous avez ici avec une lecture de la
situation mais aussi des solutions qu'on
va prendre en note merci beaucoup
d'avoir été là ce soir merci pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]